education is what remains after one has
forgotten what one has learned in school
can't explain it to a six-year-old
you don't understand it yourself
different thoughts give you an
alternative
and will help to reveal your opinion
if you want to hear interesting and not
ordinary thoughts see a selection of the
best Albert Einstein quotes
[Music]
through coincidence God maintains
anonymity
student is not a container you have to
fill
but a torch you have to light up
the Breakthrough a wall with your
forehead
you need either a large run-up or a lot
of foreheads
two things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity
and I'm not sure about the universe
life is like riding a bicycle
to keep your balance you must keep
moving
you can't blame gravity for making
people fall in love
anyone who has never made a mistake has
never tried anything new
order is needed only for a fool
genius rules over chaos
a clever person solves the problem
a wise person avoids it
[Music]
God does not play dice
you should not teach your students
anything
you just have to create the conditions
in which they will learn on their own
it is better to believe than not to
believe
because with faith everything becomes
possible
try not to become a man of success
rather become a man of value
I know not with what weapons World War
III will be fought
but World War IV will be fought with
sticks and stones
[Music]
science without religion is lame
religion without science
is blind
no one itches if it doesn't itch
if a is success in life
then a equals X Plus y plus Z
where X's work Y is play
and z
is to keep your mouth shut
any fool can know
the point is to understand
morality is the basis of all human
values
problems cannot be solved with the same
level of thinking that created them
it is not that I'm so smart
but I stay with the questions much
longer
[Music]
there are only two ways to live life
the first is that miracles do not exist
the second one is like Miracles all
around
blind belief in Authority is the
greatest enemy of Truth
if a mess on the table means a mess in
the head
then what does an empty table mean
we all know that light travels faster
than sound
that's why certain people appear bright
until you hear them speak
our beliefs and ideas are often a trap
that limits our possibilities
genius is one percent Talent
and 99 percent
hard work
the over emphasis on a purely
intellectual stance in our education
often all about practice and facts
has led directly to the devaluation of
ethical values
I'd rather be an optimist
and a fool then a pessimist and right
you never fail until you stop trying
[Music]
tragedy of experiencing oneself as
separate from all others
delusion that becomes our prison
we want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal not to people or things
only a life lived for others
is a life worthwhile
words were and remain in empty sound and
serving the ideal only in words
it is impossible to die for it
but a person is created not by what a
person hears and says
but by labor and activity
[Music]
wisdom is not a product of schooling but
of the lifelong attempt to acquire it
theory is when everything is known but
nothing works
practice is when everything works
but no one knows why
we combine theory and practice nothing
works and no one knows why
the only knowledge that can advance us
on the path of development
is the knowledge that the imagination is
capable of anything
and everything that is possible in our
imagination
is possible in reality
[Music]
only those who attempt the Absurd
can achieve the impossible
what a sad era when it is easier to
smash an atom
than a prejudice
foreign
truth is that which stands the test of
experience
[Music]
life is a preparation for the future
and the best preparation for the future
is to live as if there were none
mathematics is the only perfect way to
fool yourself
[Music]
a true sign of intelligence is not
knowledge but imagination
the only source of knowledge is
experience
there is only one path to Greatness
and that path is through suffering
[Music]
possessions
outward success publicity luxury to me
these have always been contemptible
I believe that a simple and unassuming
manner of life is best for everyone
best for both the body and the mind
when a blind bug crawls over the surface
of a ball
it does not notice that the path it is
making is curved
you might have noticed it
they say that everything that happens is
for the better and it is strictly up to
us to turn our loss into our victory
[Music]
sufficient Simplicity for every wise man
and it is Simplicity that makes him wise
for God is simple
such is his substance and souls
the only sure way to avoid making
mistakes
is to have no new ideas
[Music]
for those of us who believe in physics
the dividing line between past present
and future
is only an illusion
no matter how solid it may be
what is right is not always popular
and what is popular is not always right
ethical human behavior must be based on
empathy education and community
relations
no religious basis is required for this
time is what prevents everything from
happening at once
three great forces rule the world
stupidity
fear
and greed
you should talk to everyone the same way
whether it's a scavenger or a university
president
[Music]
the world is the dangerous place to live
not because of the people who are evil
but because of the people who don't do
anything about it
past is dead future is uncertain
present is all you have
so eat drink and live merry
the laws of mathematics that have
anything to do with the real world are
unreliable
an unreliable mathematical laws have
nothing to do with the real world
intelligence is not the ability to store
information
but to know where to find it
since the mathematicians have taken up
the theory of relativity
I no longer understand it myself
the intelligent person avoids three
things in life
in youth
lust
in maturity arrogance
in old age greed
let us not forget that human Knowledge
and Skills alone cannot lead Humanity to
a happy and dignified life
do not grow old no matter how long you
live never cease to stand like Curious
children before the great mystery into
which we were born
the woman who follows the crowd
will usually go no further than the
crowd
the woman who walks alone
is likely to find herself in places no
one has ever been before
Revenge
strong people forgive
intelligent people ignore
it's strange to be known so universally
and yet
so lonely
the important thing is not to stop
questioning
Curiosity has its own reason for
existence
five things to never share with anyone
your problems your projects
your ideas
your mistakes and regrets from the past
your income
never memorize something that you can
look up
[Music]
example isn't another way to teach
is the only way to teach
once we accept our limits
we go beyond them
we have collected these quotes from
Albert Einstein who not only elaborated
the theory of relativity but also made
many other important contributions to
science
a journey into his mind is an experience
that we should absolutely appreciate
the quotes from him are full of life
experiments and faith